the action film the misfits follows a
group of vigilantes who convince
prison escape artist richard pace played
by pierce brosnan
to help them pull off a gold heist in
the fictional country
of jazirastam the gold is originally
meant to finance
terrorist activities and a man named
schultz
is storing the fortune for a terrorist
organization
in one of his many high security prisons
with a team of misfit criminals
including con artist ringo skilled
fighter violet
and the mysterious prince pace and
company hatch a plan to steal their
bounty from a jazirastan penitentiary
their basic intention is to give the
entire prison population severe food
poisoning
dress up as medical personnel then sneak
out with the gold
a simple plan not exactly let's dive
into the multiple twists at the end of
the misfits
steal the goal stop the terrorists let's
go to prison shall we
the personal antagonism between schultz
and richard pace is obvious from the
beginning of the movie
due to the heavy implication that pace
previously slept with schultz's wife
schultz therefore has a vendetta against
pace
and pace reciprocates the rivalry by
humiliating shultz whenever possible
this motivation explains the reasoning
behind the numerous
outlandish diversions and red herrings
during the robbery
first by giving the entire prison
population food poisoning
the team causes hundreds of inmates to
suffer intense
vomiting and intestinal distress this
throws the institution into chaos
and allows the robbers to take advantage
of the distracted staff during the
pandemonium
however for pace the health of the
convicts is simply a means to an end
when wick expresses concern about their
well-being
pace heartlessly brushes off the matter
pace's main objective was to embarrass
schultz in his own facility regardless
of the collateral damage to hundreds of
people who have nothing to do with his
personal vendetta
secondly it's eventually revealed that
the gold bars weren't transported as
bricks
but instead melted down into the shape
of a statue
while schultz's team chases after a van
they presume is carrying the riches
the real gold is wheeled out of the
facility under the pretense of repairing
the sculpture
this means schultz is further disgraced
when he catches up to the van
only to find it empty once schultz does
catch the van
pace's crew is outmanned and outgunned
that is
until a fleet of soldiers with a
military aircraft inexplicably emerged
from the sand dunes
despite there being no cover for miles
around these men
are supposedly under the command of the
prince the regiment
surrounds schultz claiming to be from
the fictional sovereign nation
of salon whether this is another trick
or
reveal that the prince really is royalty
remains
somewhat ambiguous but the tactic does
allow them to leave
unharmed what isn't ambiguous however is
that the vigilante thieves condemn
schultz to death by divulging his
whereabouts
to abu hirawa the head of the terrorist
organization they just robbed
as to why hirawa would punish his lackey
in charge of protecting the gold
instead of going after those directly
responsible for swindling his wealth
standing right in front of him that
remains an unanswered question
even if hirawa believed that the prince
was royalty from a sovereign nation
he has no reason to care about the
status of the thieves who stole his
treasure
for that matter if the group really was
trying to make the world a better place
and stop
terrorism why didn't they kill hirawa
right then
they had a literal squadron of soldiers
surrounding the area
they could have brought down the head of
an international terrorist organization
and destabilized his entire
establishment they already displayed
that they're not above
killing people as violet has killed a
number of guards during the course of
the film
so why not one more death for the cause
i killed them for the final bait and
switch of the misfits
schultz's goons are holding hope hostage
and just as she's about to be executed
it's revealed that violet was the one
being held captive
which spells bad news for those guys as
she slays her abductors with ease
how these kidnappers mistook a blonde
white woman for a brunette
korean-american
is another unsolved mystery were they
not given a general description
or a photo from her instagram similarly
in the penultimate scene of the movie
it appears that richard pace has gone
back on his word and stolen the gold for
himself
but he returns to the team remorseful
the gilded statue in tow
when watching the misfits the audience
is in the same shoes as schultz
due to the many false trails the script
sets up
it's easy to become just as confused
about what's going on
as the people being robbed though one or
two plot twists can be exciting
too many curveballs tend to result in
whiplash but that's the narrative's
entire
intention to keep us on our toes
throwing us from point to point
and keep us constantly guessing if
that's the goal of the misfits
then mission accomplished check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
one